shoulder to shoulder this is western
unity on full display
with fresh purpose nato allies
attracting world attention as the
kremlin threatens global peace
the days to come
are likely to be worse
with more death
more suffering
and more destruction
as russian armed forces
bring in heavier
weaponry
and continue their attacks across the
country
and around this table the increasing
russian aggression tests the limit of
nato the alliance doesn't support a
ukrainian no-fly zone but it has
bolstered its eastern flank
members know they must do more to stop
putin we've been very coordinated in
sanctions we've shown huge unity it's
having a big effect in russia but we now
need to do more we particularly need to
look at the oil and gas sector how do we
reduce our dependence across europe on
russian gas had we cut off the funding
to vladimir putin's war machine
and as ministers met inside ukrainians
gathered outside their voices loud their
message clear defend ukraine demand
europe for leaders here diplomatic paths
remain the root out of war the trouble
is they're hard to find and while the
west might be emboldened with its
newfound solidarity president pusin
shows no sign of backing down
at the eu they discussed europe's
reliance on russian energy other leaders
invited as putin's invasion pulls the
western world together
it's also about
an assault on some very basic principles
that we established together
after two world wars to make sure that
we wouldn't see another one
principles that are at the heart of an
international system that
has a responsibility to preserve peace
and security among nations
russia's response a bullish rebuttal
today's meeting
is another attempt by kiev authorities
to kindle artificial hysteria around
what is happening in ukraine
the west can't afford to stop talking
but so far there's little sign the
kremlin is listening laura bundock sky
news brussels